wait oh wow somebody press e on is how
do I there's no e activation there's a
light switch
[Music]
yeah nice oh my gosh did this like
faulted I I wanted to read a book and I
create I suffered this power just fell
through the [ __ ] ceiling why would
you turn the lights off the one over
here makes it rain like you're dropping
money in a pub yeah what's some drinks
that's cool hey word Marco I'm whoa
how does the black guy always have to be
the musician wow thank you Mike for not
yelling at you by the way that was
delightful that's where we're going in
the actual adventurers Club to do some
more research accept Jesus Christ as
your Savior as your a stabber what
there's a makeout party going on a part
of it and that's pretty upsetting
straight whoa I'm going to has friends
into the mines you all keep making out
in the dark over there we're going help
I'm being attacked on the dance floor
help uniform is attacking me your boobs
are too surgical I want to see this book
does whoa ski come here
we're dancing No so please don't grind
okay you grind me and then kill me
that's how I Rory marries II know I
gotta go I'm super slow and I can't find
him
no it's just you and me behind
yeah he's been the white this whole time
you like you're on your own on this one
my friend oh yes dude I found a minecart
into the pyramid
yeah there's yeah into the pyramid
that's where I was you guys there yeah
oh wait did you die already
let's go to the minecart yeah yeah
follow me it's just super easy to get to
it does it actually move you pull switch
my god you're just now telling us about
this yelling you were all making out on
the dance floor I was Australian riding
on the dance right right sorry whatever
go through here you're wrong here
there's a bait out with my gun is all
big this thing you open it up in the
minecart and police never lets that face
on the wall again touch that face I want
to just go without incident okay you
guys ride I'll walk I've already ridden
that's nice yeah let's just make sure we
all know maybe I won't even look at you
I'm just guiding your way I'm the humble
guy yeah where is this gonna take us
really these two I like how you're
walking inside of this thing if you see
that walking along with the minecart
[Music]
there's another entrance to the pyramid
it's a way out come with me now oh hold
on there's booby traps in there though
yeah I just moved somebody I don't wanna
go first cuz I'm not the murderer so
where are the traps
what's with this golden idol its sides
this right here
what are the spikes what are the spikes
artifacts okay not fair right you know
that's not very let me tickle your toes
this is the murdered stop yeah just
listen to me just trust me one of those
two is for sure of the murder okay I'm
gonna swim out and go find him you stay
there and watch who's dead who's alive
I'm dead Yankee Adam is the murderer
that seems a bit hard for a second
that's round yeah probably happened
there's clearly a dead body here yeah I
see only a knife mark in it as well hmm
okay Miko I trust you where the [ __ ] is
Adam I don't know and it was blended
into the water he's like that shark that
you see in pools all the time sneaky
little ninja whatever you guys do
don't go under the water I am under the
water I'm not going
see if I fail step 1 so well I'm a
pastor swimmer you down here name is
Zulu which is clearly African my name is
Miko which is like with away nyan or
something agents can't swim oh look out
Wow where were you hiding what oh god
bolon god damn monster
[Music]